foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones
in-house of the Dragon update video in
this video we're gonna have a look at
the incredible news regarding House of
the dragon's second season as you can
see by the name of this video we just
might see the night King and or his army
of the Dead during the new season of
House of the Dragon that's right my
friends the night King's Undead Army has
already been seen on House of the Dragon
set while they're filming the new season
make sure all of you get ready because
our icy enemies from the north might be
back in a big way now before I show you
this incredibly exciting new information
I have to let all of you know about this
amazing new offer I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video skillshare
skillshare is the largest online
learning community for creatives with
thousands of online classes and members
skillshare has classes on a wide variety
of creative topics including
illustration graphic design film video
freelance creative writing music
production and that's only a small
fraction now if you're looking for ways
to level up in your life or start a new
side hustle skillshare has career Focus
classes for you too their mission is to
make a more creative life possible for
everyone around the world as a content
creator I've been using skillshare for
years to evolve in my career and
continue bringing you the most engaging
content possible but the two new classes
that I find very interesting are make AI
work for you bright creative block and
chat GPT for creatives these new classes
are an amazing way to help you learn how
to use chat GPT and Adobe Firefly to
brainstorm and generate new ideas they
would be incredibly beneficial for those
of you who might want to make videos of
your own one day the first 1 000 of you
to sign up for skillshare using my link
will get a one month free trial just go
to my link down in the description of
this video to take the next step in your
creative Journey you don't want to miss
out on this amazing new offer once again
I'd like to thank skillshare for
sponsoring today's video
now this very exciting breaking news is
brought to you by our friends over at
rodanian intelligence according to their
Source the second season of House of the
Dragon might bring back the White
Walkers and the army of the Dead their
new article says the second season of
HBO's hit series House of the Dragon
starring Emma Darcy Matt Smith and
Olivia Cook races for the finish line of
its filming schedule with location
shoots wrapped in bornwood Surrey at the
end of August now the cameras are
rolling at leavesden Studios and we have
some interesting information from that
studio the information comes from the
fact that a reference board labeled
Undead was spotted in a crowd makeup
Booth of House of the Dragon season 2 at
least in studios now what that actually
means is this is for the extras if you
focus on that white board that's sitting
on the desk you can see there are many
different examples of what the undead
Army should look like they very well
could be using that as a reference while
they're doing the makeup of many
different extras for the new season of
House of the Dragon now for those of you
who don't know already we will be
heading back to the far North in this
new season of the show if you follow all
of my videos then you already know this
information has been leaked online not
only have we already seen the wall and
unboxed phds video but we've also
already seen the Night's Watch while
they're filming new scenes for the
second season
foreign
most fans believe we will see the wall
and the Night's Watch while Jace is in
the north visiting house Stark of
Winterfell if you remember he left
Dragonstone for Winterfell at the end of
the first season this will be one of his
many stops during that Journey while
he's there Jason Lord Stark will most
likely go see the wall and as Guardians
maybe Jason Lord Stark will go out
beyond the wall with the Knights watch
and run into the whites there or maybe
we will see a separate scene of the
Night's Watch encountering the army of
the Dead on their own it's really hard
to say right now although this is not in
George R Martin's Fire and Blood it
still has me very excited to see them
again nonetheless another thing that
could happen is maybe the Night's Watch
will tell Jace and or Lord Stark about
the legends of the white walkers then
maybe we might see them during some
flashback scene now just because we see
this on the Whiteboard with the images
of the undead does not necessarily mean
we will see them next season the only
thing I'm wondering though is why have
it there at all unless you're going to
use them redanian's new article also
suggests maybe they're using it as a
reference for images of the regular
Undead maybe those who have fallen
during one of the major battles we will
surely see this season we've already
seen more than enough evidence of that
during mid-season we will see the blacks
and the greens fighting the battle at
rook's rest maybe these are actually
images of the bodies that have been
burned by the dragons but once again why
does it say the undead as we all know
that's a direct reference to the night
King's Army I don't know about all of
you but I find this new information to
be very interesting it now has me even
more excited for what we might see next
season now let's assume for a second the
undead are in this new season we already
have the wall confirmed and we have a
video of the Night's Watch Riders
filming in the woods so if we were to
see them we'd see the undead in whatever
sequence those other elements are
involved we know for a certain we'll see
the north when she carries valerion
flies to Winterfell to meet Craig and
Stark the theory based on these wall
sets is that they will visit the wall
during that time however with that being
said lore Wise It's a head scratcher the
undead or whites are raised by the White
Walkers or the others which are dormant
in this time of history and no one even
thinks they're real
there's a choice of the white walkers
white walkers have been gone for
thousands of years
so he was like
no one has seen them for thousands of
years before the events of the first
novel A Game of Thrones so it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense unless they
find a way to make it make sense somehow
for all we know Ryan condo wants to go
in his own direction or who knows maybe
HBO demanded the white walkers be in the
show as a way to bring back more fans
from the original Game of Thrones series
as we all know the night King is one of
the most recognizable characters from
this series it would most definitely get
more fans excited for the thought of
another battle with the undead now I am
only speculating of course as I said
already this is not confirmed until we
actually see it happen during one of the
episodes either way let me know some of
your thoughts down below why do you
think they have all these images of the
undeadted House of the Dragon studio
will we actually see them next season
and if we do see them what do you think
will happen in that scene will there be
a battle or will it simply be a
flashback while one of the men of the
Night's Watch are retelling some old
Legend I'm interested in hearing what
all of you have to say about this one
what do you think it means for next
season feel free to leave me some fun
theories if you have any as always I
want to thank all of you for watching
another video I hope all of you have a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye
foreign
[Music]